[Musique]
Oui
c'est moi qui décide
Trame
7 et j'accepte
sans avoir la version noire d'action si elles sont
statique de nombreux groupes
[Musique]
dans cette possibilité
le disque est une fiction de clairon qui, comme
Oui
les gadgets
parfois juste un monde fait et beaucoup
capacité
Oui
premier
médias
Suarez
89 condition persistante de l'eau de Javel
Allons-y
comme je l'ai expliqué
en eux
minutes
ef
avec de la viande
pas de genre
J'écoute du valencien
m
comme un enfant
james jones
bien que le tremblement de terre
sept
voir
composé de six plans
à l'heure 16
ef
entre les dents
on lui dit
Afrique de l'Est
Oui
myriam cameros et le pouvoir des archives
non
les apprécierait et nous avons des bâtiments
je
mais non
[Musique]
non
je suis comme toi
je le consomme
nous avons dit un handicap
decider
[Musique]
le lacet
où comment fonctionne la ligne
et coupe nous nous sentons sexuels
et actif
étudiant comme
barreur et magie
si la table avec vous les gars
à ce monde et ces temps
ré
et montrera vos devis
dans le jienense du triomphe
actions policières
avec vous
bonjour ils existent
dans son plus
L'Ambassadeur
vous ferez les secteurs populaires de votre
voir
teste moi
Quoi
être une mère
Oui
la texture du suisse
mais
Francesco
joseph avec clarté et langage
après
s'il y a un dieu
sa
elles ou ils
parce que
au revoir
dans la version avion
très peu
sans peau et avec le même
c'est un plan vu à votre droite
sommeil
je
A 26 miles de la planète
ce sont des générations dures
mais
Savez-vous quels sont leurs enfants ?
lorsque
des millions décideront
Oh
ef
avec ça
as
Quoi
ils ne sont pas la personne
Alors
et sculpture de nous manger
pour le monde
Oui
rêver
doux devant
[Musique]
mais
plus
étaient
en apesanteur
m
eh bien kar wai dit
un m
égal
il il
Oui
ce sont mes actions
voir
ou oui
avec moins de points
de nouveau
Hé bien oui
ou oui
pour le personnel
comme un tricycle
plus
[Musique]